so what other audio move immune diseases
do you think could be assisted by this
well we we do a lot of MS as per our
number one indication we just finished a
clinical trial prospective clinical
trial we submitted for publication and
should be it should be coming out in the
next month or so and and and
statistically significantly the these
patients improve dramatically and as far
as side-effect profile it was highly
minimal I mean field headaches and a few
few flu-like symptoms things like that
how many people this was with twenty
people and one of the one of the
individuals actually is clinically is
perfect and all of his legions went away
and and we only did one treatment with
these typically with ms it's more
refractory than rheumatoid arthritis
rheumatoid arthritis usually after one
treatment people get a ton of benefit
with MS they usually see after two or
three treatments that they they really
they see the most benefit we only did
one treatment in this in this trial but
one gentleman had three lesions in his
brain all three lesions completely
disappeared so ms is a big thing
rheumatoid arthritis is that is a big
thing and I tell you there's stories in
the not stories but wreak you know
people talking about with their
responses and it's pretty incredible
there's one lady that her husband was a
PhD physicist he carried on working just
so she could afford just so she could
have insurance to afford the medications
which were around a hundred grand a year
for her to get treated for a rheumatoid
arthritis and she came down about it'll
be it's a little over three years ago
November and she hasn't been on any
medication since she actually started
walking around the mall when she was in
Panama and then when she got home she's
completely you know pain-free and she's
been pain-free for three years and her
husband finally retired because he
didn't care about you know having the
insurance to pay for these very
expensive drugs that she was taken so MS
rheumatoid arthritis lupus we don't we
don't have a lupus protocol there's
there's a group in China that's that's
published six really good papers on
lupus it's very very effective in in
their trials we haven't done it yet
and and in autism you know it's it's not
considered an autoimmune disease but we
have a trial we just completed our
autism trial with 33 33 enrollees with
very good results many many of those
kids became not autistic after treatment
that's confusing to me because you're
talking about people that are young
right so why why would it have such a
benefit for them well I wrote an article
in 2007 about why these cells should be
good for autism and and and basically it
it's and it's the most downloaded
article this journals ever had and it's
something like 75,000 people have
downloaded a scientific journal article
which really doesn't happen very often
but kids people with autism have
inflammatory things going on in their
body a lot of times in the gut there are
in the in the in the at the end of the
small intestine there are these
inflammatory nodules that look a lot
like Crohn's disease and they secrete
these this inflammation that thing goes
to the brain inflames the white matter
of the brain the white matter that brain
swells decreases the blood flow to the
brain all that's in you know intertwined
and then just a few years ago there was
a study that came out and this is what
this is what allowed us to go forward
with our clinical trial they found that
there are these two inflammatory
molecules that are MDC and tart and
they're perfectly correlate with the
severity of symptoms of autism and so we
measured not only those two but another
30-some biomarkers we measure we did
quantitative EEG s we did a lot of
standardized scoring stores scoring with
a neurologist that that read them you
know be before treatment during
treatment after treatment so I believe a
lot of the problems with autism have
stem from the inflammatory status and
these cells are definitely
anti-inflammatory you know they've had
some benefit with changing the diet and
changing the gut biome of the kids with
autism and they've made some benefits
for that and which they they believe is
also connected to
inflammation yeah absolutely if your if
your immune systems freaking out every
time you eat a piece of bread and that
in that immune systems thrown out
molecules that are swelling your brain
and inflaming your brain then it makes
complete sense and yeah you know the I
think in general the the the people with
autism that do the best are the ones
that get that address before they come
down you know there's some other doctors
that do functional medicine and they
look at their diet they look at see if
they have any heavy metals and that sort
of thing and the ones that just are slam
dunk do the best i've been cleaned up
before they come down
[Applause]